hey guys welcome back to the space
Waterland podcast time surely talk sport
Rugby World Cup preview show now
obviously no one's sent in any um new
names for us last week so we're gonna
have to keep running with that even
though it's an absolute shambles but I
guess everyone is still focused on what
is important which is the Rugby World
Cup and our water first round of footy
and we've even got a special guest with
us joining us no man knows the European
version of rugby better than this man
he's watched plenty of code from the
best seat of the house the bench over
the last five years so looking forward
to having his Insight on the preview
shoulders Jacob Atkins welcome mate hey
thanks for having me on Jim yeah mate
you don't learn uh you don't learn like
the game anything like being mine top on
the touchline to the coaches you hear
all the good conversations you run a TDS
and uh yeah but uh thanks have a million
boys it's uh I had a listen to the
preview last week and um Jay's gym I
think you must have just asked me to
come on this to have someone to disagree
with because both you boys are
predicting the same singing off the same
hymn sheet so hopefully I can uh offer a
different opinion exactly mate that's
exactly why you're on to give us a bit
of reality we're probably a little bit
southern hemisphere heavy on the show um
that's probably where we spend a lot of
our time watching our code so I'm
looking forward to having your inside
and a few disagreements although this
week's
it's hard to disagree on too many but we
might find one or two but of course as
always everyone will know who else is on
the show it's of course surely talk
sports the most iconic voice in New
Zealand um he's back on coming from
Greece after watching the first round in
France he's over in Greece now just
living the absolute dream how are you
led yeah good mate can't complain sun's
out slowly getting rid of the Old Winter
sock tan as well which has been a real
bonus so by the time I get back to New
Zealand I'll be able to rock the jandals
without copping a bit of flack from the
boys but it was it was a tough shift in
Paris for you to say the French got one
up over us both on the field and off the
field they certainly let me know about
it so it was good to escape get over to
Greece and just kind of recoup before
heading back over to watch some all
black wins yeah what was it like what
was the atmosphere like in in the mix oh
it was pretty crazy eh they're a
different level of passion that I always
say kiwis loved their sport but I think
the French are next level like just
crying during the anthem every scrum
they won they were just giving it big
ones like they'd won the World Cup
lighting flares every penalty to tell
you what great place to be a goal kicker
in New Zealand you get heckled but they
worship them over there and then just
random like outbreaks into the national
anthem just like you know just the whole
place is quiet and then some bloke will
just spark it up I can't imagine us
kiwis doing that so it was a good taste
of a different side of the culture for
sure it sounds like good stuff I reckon
you would have been starting out some
random hackers surely yeah the hacker
isn't really my go-to unless I've had a
fair few to be fair so
I keep the hackers away uh maybe if we
were on the front foot dominating then I
would have ripped out a couple but yeah
save that for maybe the big games oh the
final with RTS under the stacks looking
forward to seeing that
and a great news guys we have got a new
sponsor on for the podcast it's meant
undies the best undies on the planet
obviously Jerome kano's business so stay
tuned with few giveaways of gift
vouchers for mint Andy's on the Woodland
Instagram page might be a few
competitions or maybe someone who just
goes really good at Fantasy but a few
will be sent you away let me know your
address in Greece silly and you can try
these things on for yourself because no
doubt you probably need a new pair over
there as well yeah a bit of an impromptu
photo shoot poolside and Mykonos you
Rick and we'll see how that goes
yeah it could work anyway we'll get into
the code um firstly Ethan blackett is
over it has come true how good is it
have you spotted the man over there in
the flesh yet no but I I do wonder if
there was a bit of insider trading there
hey obviously you're pretty close with
him so maybe you got the tip before the
boys did and you got in on that one
because that is one of the great early
crows of all time and no doubt you'll
probably take that one to your grave I
see you've been trumpeting it all over
Instagram Again re-sharing The Reel just
to let people know where they heard it
first so well played from you mate
certainly wasn't inside in Trader
because even Ethan I noticed he said he
was the last thing he was expecting so
um he's a very humble man but he said it
very honestly and like it sort of proved
it hasn't been listening to enough water
lead he hasn't been watching the preview
show so I was a little bit disappointed
and I'm there because it could have been
one step ahead for sure what do you
think about Ethan Blackadder Jake give
us an honest opinion from your side of
the fence because you love to beg a kiwi
this is absolute crook mate hey Jim I've
known you long enough there is no way
you didn't know something going on
working and working in Super Rugby
you're the most crook bloke I've ever
met this is this is a setup you're
playing with the ABS coaches playing the
long game to build what I love but um
yeah look I mean he just adds incredible
depth to already amazing but doesn't he
like there's nothing more to say the
adapt some of these teams in the
competition this year is scary eh like
you look at injuries or like when we go
through the previous week There's a
couple of teams rotating a bit and
there's just no drop off in quality as
there's just players coming in adding
more quality more Firepower with some of
these especially the big four teams like
geez it's the strongest I've seen it for
a long time yeah it's definitely the
difference say between the I guess the
stronger sides in the um relatively
minnows where they can't really rotate
this side at all but and we will get
into the footy look at uh one question
about footing snakes right on so looking
forward to getting into the real preview
stuff but we'll quickly review the games
give get your thoughts on what happened
in the weekend so obviously we'll start
with the big one that started it All
Blacks game
um hell of a start for the All Blacks
first two minutes I thought oh geez
these boys are on um
first or absolute Clinic off the kickoff
into the try and yeah it was all looking
pretty good but that was about the
extent of it what'd you make of the game
surely yeah obviously like you said
dream start but then from there on out I
thought we were kind of outplayed in
most aspects there were still some
positives
um and some real you could tell the boys
were trying hard there were some real
effort areas there where we took the
boxes but I think we were just
outclassed and it wasn't just from the
starting side it was the bench as well I
think when The Fringe Unleashed their
bench they got a massive another hit of
momentum and they were just too good I
think our discipline really hurt us I
think it was 12 penalties to four they
kicked five nudges we kicked one when
ramoff says his boot on like that you
just can't give points and opportunities
so that was a real negative and then the
second negative for me was inability to
play off back football again we've gone
back to just putting in these dinky
little nudges 50 50 type of Chip kicks
and kicking away quality position I
think we need to come up with a bit of
away when we're seeing these Rush
defenses and we aren't getting gain line
a better way to try wrestle momentum
back in our favor because preying on the
bounce of a ball isn't going to get you
the results against these top four sides
Yeah you mentioned the kicking game
there I think that was basically the
difference in the game and the French
kicking game was all over ours and we
didn't really get any results from our
contestable kicks like you're saying and
Jake you're obviously kicking game
expert what'd you make of the kicking
game the French kicked 44 times I heard
a lot of complaints around people saying
the All Blacks kick too much but the
French actually kicked 44 times way more
than us and every time we did manage to
try and run it back that was where the
French got their points from so got to
be careful with some of this kicking
game stuff but I think the French
definitely had a better kicking plan
than we did yeah 100 and like it's funny
you say that isn't it so often that's
the case where one team will cop a load
of stick online or or on the comms from
kicking more and then you have to look
at the stats and it's actually the other
team that's kicked better it's just
people notice kicks more when they're
[__] aimless kicks yeah exactly like you
mentioned those are the ones that stick
in people's memory people don't remember
good territorial kicks to to get teams
out of trouble or to find space and
generate momentum and then like you
mentioned the big one for me boys was
discipline a like the penalty count
difference is too big in a tight test
match like that and I don't think I've
ever seen anyone strike a cleaner board
and Ramos does like it like even the
best kickers of all time you see a
slight right to left or a slight left to
right that guy throws it like a dart
like you you just anything in your heart
you cannot give them a chance to get
into the game so for me yeah I thought
they let France off the hook a little
bit too uh too often sorry
and then the penalty count you give them
12 penalties he's gonna kick six of them
where do you see France
um and the overall scheme of things
obviously a good start for them but um
South Africa Island looked pretty good
as well there's England right going up
in threes for me and it's it's easier to
sit here obviously it wasn't on on last
week or the week before to say it after
a good french result but for me coming
into this tournament France were the
clear favorites
um I think for the last couple years in
Europe France and Ireland have just been
going at each other in domestically that
in the European competition the big
French clubs and and the big Irish clubs
and then in the Six Nations and just
over the last 18 months I think that
I've seen those two teams push each
other to a level that Northern
Hemisphere teams probably haven't been
at maybe since well in my lifetime
um but for me France unless they meet
Ireland in this tournament I can't see
anyone who beats France wow I think
Ireland have that I think Ireland have
their number but I just I can't if they
don't draw Ireland in the game I can't
see them losing the game this whole
tournament they've got too much depth
they've got too much quality
they've been playing in big games in the
six nations in Europe for the last
couple of years I just feel like they
are they are the hot team and it's easy
to sit here in the seat after they've
done that against New Zealand at the
weekend if if they'd lost but I've still
come here and said the same thing you
would have mate I know I know what
you're like you would have been backing
the French from a long way out but no
that's exactly why you're on mate a
different View and
um it's an interesting take because
you're right around how the French and
the Irish have been going at each other
for the last few years so
um and both teams are playing some
exceptional rugby but we'll quickly get
through these next few games obviously
Italy Namibia snake obviously you're
living in Italy give us a rundown of the
Italian side yeah this Italian side is
is a good side boy is they I think a lot
of people who maybe don't watch the Six
Nations or don't watch much European
rugby or maybe put them into that
bracket with like Georgia and some of
the other minnow teams they're
definitely in that next category up
closer to you know that second closer to
like your England's and Wales is at the
moment like it's like they are they're a
seriously well coached team they're a
seriously organized team
um I didn't like the backline setup they
started with in this game against
Namibia they started with
um garbisi playing at 10 and Tommy Allen
at 15. the second half they flipped it
they brought Tommy Allen into 10 shifted
out guard BC to 12. he's bro he's so
Italian he's so passionate so emotional
but I just think he lets that Italian
team run away with it a look sometimes
with with that emotion and Tommy Allen
he's played a lot of rugby for Quinn's
they played rugby in Scotland before
he's a much much calmer more composed
and he just gives them a better balance
but then that also frees them up to
Chuck the whip it back and fall back
like again I don't know if you've seen
much of this kid but
when he's on the wing he he's kind of in
that little 15 meter box and he doesn't
offer a lot because he must be 70 kilos
soaking work like but when they can free
him up in that free role like in you
guys obviously don't watch much football
but like that free number 10 role
um in football where he can literally
just join the game wherever he wants
they look like a different team they did
it in the second half against Namibia
and then they put what did they put 35
40 points in them in the second half so
I'd like to see them then push that
forward right love that do you think
they can beat the All Blacks
not a chance no no either a good team
and they're well organized boys but
they're not miracle workers they're
they've just been stung like some teams
have in this can't buy unlucky draws if
they were maybe in England's group do I
back them to do a job on England or
Argentina once potentially throw a pool
wide open but New Zealand and uh New
Zealand and France not a chance yeah
well that's they're safe oh that makes
me you had me going there because I
thought geez that seems good no no no no
no no no no okay next one was Australia
Georgia so I was pretty impressed with
Australia's kicking game I thought
they're really patient with theirs
pegged Georgia right down into their
half and didn't really let them get out
and then
um like we spoke about in the previous
show there's probably too much class too
much X Factor to score tries what'd you
make of this one silly yeah I think
Aussie's back three is an exciting
prospect I was pretty rough on Eddie
Jones not picking Quay Cooper and going
with Ben Donaldson as kind of that
utility but maybe this was that Master
stroke that the Aussie fans have been
waiting for from Uncle Eddie because
he's played a few rough cards so far but
maybe that was as well out and then that
back three with kodan Betty and big Mark
they kind of have that X Factor about
them which they can dish up some unusual
attacking pictures to opposition sides
so I think this is exciting for
wallabies fans and saying that I don't
think they were as good as the
scoreboard suggested there's still some
patchiness to their game and yeah that
that game this week against Fiji is just
mouth-watering because the fijians
showed that on their day and I'm sure
we'll speak about that soon but they're
going to push the Aussies right down to
the wire but I think Aussie and Ben
Donaldson they might have found
themselves a bit of a Bolter maybe a
potential hero for them in their world
cup campaign yeah I agree like I was
impressed with them I didn't know he was
as quick as he was showed a fair turn of
pace when he was in in the spat in space
so uh yeah I was impressed by him and
like you say that Aussie Fiji game this
weekend is gonna oh it's got to be the
game of the round doesn't it it's so
hard to predict and um both sides will
throw everything at it they'll get to
the next game England versus Argentina
we're speaking of kicking games this was
a kicking game what'd you make of this
one snake
right this is a really weird one I met I
messaged Jim about this I I after the
game I watched it and I I didn't know
how to feel at all I want to start by
saying like first of all like
geez hell of a job from the boys to get
up 14 men for 70 plus minutes in a World
Cup against a good Argentina team under
the pressure that those boys are under
at the moment is uh is a hell of a job
I'm so proud of every player that took
the field for England to actually get
them over the line there
um that's in terms of the boy the boys
on the field doing the job
um but in terms of The Wider picture for
England it still worries me a lot
um I I've been really surprised by how
well received the game has been back
home
I think the English media and English
social media can often be you know all
or nothing either we're amazing or we're
terrible and there's no kind of like
okay we've made a bit of progress in
some areas but there's still big big
concerns and the big concern for me with
this England team is 80 minutes of rugby
one line break and again no tries
we touched on it at the start like there
are four teams in this competition who
are seriously seriously playing a high
level of rugby at the moment and all of
those teams no matter how well you
defend over 80 minutes I'm gonna score
two tries you can defend as well as you
want and and England defended really
well in this game and like I said the
boys on the job boys on the pitch did
such a great job but we can defend as
well as we want we are going to concede
two tries against any of those big four
teams they've got great kickers so
straight away you're looking at 14
points you had two penalties on top of
that that's 20 points
so we're asking if we're not going to
score tries we're asking George Ford to
kick what nine goals to win us a game of
rugby you can do it well mate if he
keeps hitting three drop goals and
finishes the rest off the T then geez
fair play to him but England win this
England win this game for three reasons
for me is one Argentina incredibly
disappointing that they were for me the
big disappointment of the round I think
um I agree maybe a slightly new
experience for them coming in
potentially to a group in the World Cup
as a favorite and with the favorable
draw potentially looking at like a a
favor they've obviously been to
semi-finals before but a favorable run
to a semi-final
um it looked like they were scared to me
uh like um they look really long
confident and
um we've all been in that situation on
the field where you don't know whether
to stick or twist and I think they got
themselves in that little situation a
few times against 14 men England
the second point was that George Ford
Master Class like that is the best
example of how to play when you're down
to 14 players in a World Cup game with a
team that can't get you any line breaks
apps are the the best performance I've
ever seen him have in terms of the
situation and then the context of the
game
um and the third point was just like I
said the shift the boys play in for 14
Lads to to play for 70 minutes I can't
tell you how tired some of those boys
would have been at the end but that's
why England win the game and I still
have serious serious concerns about the
team moving forward in terms of the
the the sort of lack of any kind of
creativity potential in attack they just
they just I haven't seen them offer
anything that gets me excited and again
no tries yeah no tries right it is it is
interesting and it's a it's a
fascinating Insight because I do think
that was definitely a masterclass on how
to play with 14 men like they didn't
have to overplay but like you say that
that's not just being a one-off that's
been what they've been doing
um every week for the last sort of few
years so it'll be interesting to see how
they whether they adapt this weekend
playing against Japan very different
styles so
um it'll be a good one to watch but
great one for them I I wasn't picking
them to beat Argentina but like you say
really disappointed with the way
Argentina played especially against the
14 men English side I just wasn't quite
sure what their plan was there so
um yeah it's going to be tough for them
now but we'll get to the next one Japan
vs Chile nothing really changed for me
in this one got to see a few Chilean
players in the flesh plan on live TV
which was good to see some of them can
play eh what'd you make of this one
silly yeah it was an interesting game I
think the scoreboard flattered Japan
towards the end though until they were
actually a lot better than what I
expected so well done to them it's just
so cool to see them inward in the World
Cup clearly they're loving their
experience and they're a lot better of a
football side than I expected so I
thought it was quite a positive kind of
debut for them worrying for Japan man
like just the fall off from their last
World Cup through to now it's not great
I I think they've really taken a couple
steps back and I think they'll struggle
throughout this tournament but focus on
the positives and and well done to Chile
it was cool to see something a bit
different from them yeah I agree but
we'll get to the next one South Africa
vs Scotland now South Africa just sort
of strangled them and typical South
Africa fashion what'd you make of this
game snakey no I thought South Africa's
defense was phenomenal I was watching
the game and thinking like that that is
a seriously talented Scotland backline
who've shown some serious rather over
the last few Six Nations I mean
obviously I'm an England supporter and
we've not got close to them for the last
two and a half three years
um and that South Africa team shut them
down like I was watching the game trying
to think what they could
how could Scotland change us up to to
create something for them and I was like
maybe a flat kick pass maybe a 50 like
that's yeah they ran that hissing they
run that hissing line out starter play
you see from the overthrow with the
reverse uh reverse Ball but then other
than that like that is a seriously
dangerous Scotland backline in South
Africa apart from that one starter play
where they got them they just shut them
down like you obviously don't need to
talk about South Africa as set piece I
actually thought Scotland did a really
good job at set piece for the first 50
minutes but then those boys bring on the
bomb squad a and it's like imagine you
play against the best front row in the
world for 50 minutes and then they bring
on the second best front row in the
world for 30 minutes like imagine how
that would kill your morale yeah um but
but that was it for me like just Finn
Russell's a hell of a player there's
some serious seriously talented with
other guys in that back line they're
really really well coached and organized
attack and they just they could do
nothing against it that defense sort of
mean for me yeah and what about you
silly I know you rate South Africa you
put them a big chance of going all the
way did nothing change for you after
that one obviously yeah well I actually
really rate Scotland so I think the fact
that South Africa were able to do that
against a quality Scottish site kind of
bumped South Africa up more in my
rankings I I really enjoyed watching
Scotland play over the last kind of 18
months they've been a massive improver
for me and just the exciting brand of
football that they play like snakey
mentioned that line out move I wish they
executed that and just one more pass and
they would have scored one other great
kind of set piece rugby tries but just
wasn't to be there's always a Winger in
the team that's got that show and going
and yeah I think South Africa they just
know the big occasions don't they they
just always stand up and they seem to
peek right at the right time six weeks
ago back in New Zealand they looked
awful and everyone was kind of saying
that they're no chance but then their
last two performances have been massive
so they're right up there it's just
gonna come quarterfinals time who they
face that kind of determines how far
they go yeah man that cool to find is
going to be tough as an all-back fan
whether you want to play South Africa
Island I'm not sure and that's a game
that we missed too by the way island
Romania
um not many surprises they're a massive
score from Ireland who put out a strong
Squad and were just far too clinical but
good to see Johnny Sexton back out there
running a mark as he does so did anyone
change your opinion on Ireland or
Romania from that game no not at all
it's a dream start from isn't it similar
to what I mentioned about Argentina the
other day like when you come in to a
World Cup as the number one ranked team
in the world and they'll be expecting a
lot lot more from themselves than
previous years like at home in Europe
this is definitely seen as like a golden
generation of Irish Rugby and I'm sure a
lot of those guys in that camp probably
feel like it's now or never for them
just you know they've been phenomenal in
the last few Six Nations they're ranked
number one in the world and
and carrying that into a tournament can
be really difficult for teams sometimes
when they're not used to it so to start
against Romania and actually have
I don't want to disrespect Romania but I
have a game where you essentially can
get some meters in your legs get some
confidence up get get everyone to get
their hands on the ball like it's a
dream start for a World Cup situation
for them isn't it yeah and it's another
easy one again for them this week too
really so they get to really build up
into their Rugby World Cup like you say
but the last game was the game of the
round for me Wales vs Fiji loved
watching this one Fiji throw everything
man I love watching that side play
um but Wales just hung on at the end
there and
um what could have been if Raja I caught
that they weren't stopping him so um
small moments to decide these games
these close games and there's definitely
one of those games where
um it was decided by small moments and
then everyone When A Game's decided by
small moments everyone chooses the one
man in the middle that it's his fault so
what did you make of this game snake in
terms of Wales like again I don't know
how much media coverage you guys will
get on context away I was like this is a
huge win for them with the last 18
months considered
um similar to England
um that there is serious serious like
well-reported domestic issues in terms
of the infrastructure and funding in
Welsh rugby at the moment you obviously
saw a load of very very high profile
Wells players retire like weeks out from
the World Cup
there's a lot of guys going off to
France a lot of guys
um you know leaving the country
um with all those things considered and
and how poor they've been for the last
18 months like this was a massive game
for those Lads and
to make the quarter finals at this world
cup on that backdrop of the last 18
months for them would be a huge success
and I was really impressed with Danae
like
Jesus looked at some of the stats offers
they made 130 230 tackles to fiji's 80.
like that is a hell of a shift from from
those Lads and uh look they weren't
pretty to watch at times and they
certainly got lucky with with some some
calls and and maybe a bit of
um sort of like lack of accuracy at
times from Fiji and I think they really
did miss having their regular guy at 10
um but look Wales got over the line and
ultimately that's all they have to do in
this world cup they have to just try and
get over the line and get the best
results possible they certainly did that
what'd you make of Fiji Surly oh they're
just a pleasure to watch aren't they
like I think as a mutual fan when you
sit down and watch this game like that
is that's the type of rugby you want to
see being played so many teams now we
mentioned the kicking games some of the
inaccuracies around their game plan but
Fiji they kind of just throw caution to
the wind and that's what rugby is kind
of all about so I was almost more gutted
to see them lose than the All Blacks to
lose just because you got so emotionally
invested in that game throughout it and
I think Fiji for most kiwis anyway they
probably are second favorite side to get
behind so it was a bit heartbreaking but
also a great tip of the cap another sign
that they are right there with these
kind of top eight teams in World rugby
at the moment and they're no longer
going into these big games as underdogs
which is a Real Testament to them like
we're now speaking of them as a genuine
chance to beat the wallabies they should
have bit whales they beat England but
the fact that we're talking about Fiji
in that type of status is pretty crazy
when you wind back maybe two years ago
they were a side that would come to New
Zealand and would put 50 on them whereas
now you'd be a bit nervous taking them
on yeah you're right and like we spoke
about last week I think the drue have
had a a big say in that so it's awesome
to see that sort of reflect into the
international game but just before we
get into the preview I'll quickly review
my fantasy side and if any of you guys
want to review your one just jump in but
my side was tracking okay up until the
Japan game absolute costly game for me
had himino late withdrawn obviously it
was a 1am kickoff so I had no chance to
sub him out last minute absolutely got
it there he got zero points and my light
change in the centers I brought an old
Dylan the 13 who is an absolute gun in
the top leg over there and he ended up
with a negative one points from a yellow
card slap down so that was super costly
for me just when I was looking all right
to get quite a big score those two
um absolutely break me because the guys
I took out was the other Japanese Center
and Michael Leach who ended up combining
for 87 points so that is 87 points that
should be on my Telly but that's the
part of the game we love also no tries
for JLo I spoke about him getting sort
of two or three and as my captain I was
expecting a lot more from him but he did
rack up some stats he got a lot of
tackle breaks linebacks around meter so
he still picked up a relatively good
score so I wasn't too upset there
and the only thing that made me feel
better about my week was that my brother
captained um Dylan at 13. so he picked
up a whopping negative two from his
captain it's a huge week for him made me
feel a lot better about my round
but the biggest letdown from the game so
far has been that you can't actually
track other players scores live so you
can only see everyone else's score at
the end which is pretty disappointing
um see when you're watching the game
live you can only really see the guys
that you've got so that would be a nice
addition for World rugby if they could
add that in before the end of the world
cup
um and other than that
past score I think I was expecting the
scores to sort of be 50 points would be
a pass but I think it's a lot lower than
that guys are picking up a lot less
points than I thought they would I think
30s are sort of pass Mark and if you've
got your captain you'll be wanting
around 50s probably a pass how do you
guys go on your fantasy first round uh
well I forgot to submit my team
completely so um mate that was the first
rule of the wattle ad preview show
overseas you know on tour you often get
distracted by other things so um yeah
fair to say this week I'll be looking to
lock it down but I've probably lost uh
lost touch with the front of the pack so
it's all about Pride for me now yeah
what about you snake you would have
George Ford yeah this is a great this
this is a great section for the podcast
they uh I'm I'm not on it I'm not on it
because I mean I'm I'm already in too
many high-stakes fantasy sports League
one of them is full of absolute Crypt
looks like Blair Cowan and it's taken
them very seriously so that takes up too
much of my time to come here although
Jimmy you mooning about the time
difference mate if you've got my e-bank
details and you need me to make evening
changes for you over here mate just
shoot it my way okay damn okay we'll get
into the preview anyway even though you
don't play Fantasy this week is a great
week for Fantasy because it is all
pretty one-sided games bearing too I
think so and there could be a lot of
points on the line if you're playing
fantasy rugby or um players to watch
anyway
but we'll go through the games first
game is obviously France Uruguay
wholesale changes for France
um snake any insight to the these French
players anyone to look out for yeah
absolutely man I've got one lad and he
is absolute Razzle Anton hastoy the 10
that they've brought in this week I
think um you guys might not have seen a
huge amount of them but the the fact
that he's third choice 10 coming into
this world cup for France is more about
French Rugby's depth than it does about
him he is a serious player he uh he was
the 10 for La Rochelle this year took
them to a European Cup Final obviously
he's been working with Ronan o'gara so
there's that massive uh sort of
Crusaders influence that comes through
Raj a massive focus on quick ball you
know that keep ball alive mentality Lara
shell play with and this guy just
embodies that he's Triple Threat run
pass kick he's skills Deluxe and uh yeah
for me like against a Uruguay team this
week uh you know French like you said
have obviously rotated but they don't
drop any quality and there's one thing
guaranteed this week candidates that
he's going to get quick ball from
football and like I said this guy is
Razzle loud so for me he's an easy pick
for for this game mate that is a good
shot I I didn't know much about him I
knew obviously played for Lara shell but
um yeah that's a great shout and looking
forward to seeing him out there and
probably a good option for fantasy
players but he won't be in my fantasy
team at 10 because
um there's only one man I want at my 10
Jersey this week and it's in this next
game it's all blacks versus the Nubia
DMACC the fantasy Guru he has been ever
since he started his career his game has
revolved around fantasy he's got tackle
breaks in him he's uh running meters
triceps tries the absolute fantasy king
so I'm looking to see him rack up a huge
score against Namibia and I'm looking to
even triple captain and I'm going to use
my big power play this week on a goal
kicking I think he'll move to fullback
late potentially when Richie comes on
hopefully or else I'll be a few points
there but
um who are you looking forward to seeing
out there in this all black team surely
they've obviously rung the changes as
well yeah I'm looking forward to seeing
um cam roygard go about his work I
thought we could have really done with
him off the bench last week because
impact against South Africa he was
probably the main positive from that
game where we got pumped so I'm looking
forward to seeing that Cam and DMACC
combo maybe that's a bit of a nod to
2024 and how we could move forward as an
all black side with the 910 Duo and then
also listifying anoku I think he's going
to make a massive game on the weekend on
the wing I think the Nubians are really
going to struggle to handle him so
linebacks and tries Galore he'll be
another one that I reckon you should
Chuck in your fantasy team and I'll
Chuck them in if I remember too mate hey
you're a step ahead of me I've got him
lined up into my team as well like you
said he's got the fantasy game in him
um and yeah I'm expecting a big score
from him as well next game is Samoa
chilly
tonight what do you know about these
Chileans that we don't oh the team of
what a lot jeez I loved it I loved
watching them last week boys at that
Japan game like for the first 40 minutes
I absolutely loved it man it was like
professional full contact con games like
the boys were just going at each other
it was great to watch
um like we said in the in the review
like I was I was impressed man they
there's some seriously good Runners and
some some smart footballers they just
they they really struggled and set peace
time against Japan like more wise scrum
wise they got absolutely filled in and
then I feel like it's gonna be another
step up again
for them this week and it's going to be
really tough for them to get in the game
if if their set pieces going like that
but I the one I picked to watch was the
uh the fullback ayatza sorry for any of
the uh Chile and what a lad listeners if
my pronunciation's bad I've not touched
up on my Chilean in a long time but
um really really good player uh he
looked against Japan seriously balanced
run I love that Goosey to the outside
and the big left arm friend look really
really good really difficult these guys
look really really difficult to tackle
like he's all elbows and knees when he
runs
um so maybe maybe he's cheap maybe an
outside fantasy shout for some for some
meters and maybe a score yeah nice
option I like that he did look very
classy didn't he one of my new favorites
as well but first look at Samoa for us
um obviously the buyer the first round
looking forward to seeing
and this team out there they've named a
very good squad
um a lot of X All Blacks the Lima kiwis
like bin lamb and stuff adding to the
mix I think they've got a really
powerful Squad
um I think they're a good chance
actually what do you what do you make of
them who are you looking forward to
seeing out there absolutely Yeah you
mentioned that those eggs all blacks
coming into bolster this squad and
that's what I think really gives them a
great crack they're so physical so yeah
I feel a little sorry for the Chileans
because I think they're gonna really
struggle in that contact area we saw
they like to play fast and whatnot but
some more they're coming in fresh
they're going to be looking to make a
statement and it could be some bruising
shots going in but I'm looking forward
to seeing Lena sopawanga again I've
always been a massive fan of watching
him go about his work and I think he
pushes them right up onto the edge of
those kind of top tier Nations so
fingers crossed we saw in that pacific
Nations cup they were one of the sides
that impressed me the most so they'll be
looking for a big campaign and no doubt
they're eyeing up some of those top
sides in their pool and thinking we
could be in with a real shot here I
think we mentioned in that first League
England's Samoa that last game to finish
it could be a fair bit riding on there
yeah well the way Argentina played in
the weekend yeah you'd almost be backing
um Samoa to be beating them on that
performance so yeah it's an interesting
pull that one looking forward to
following that one our next game is
Wales vs Portugal so I don't know much
about Portugal you probably do snake but
and I know you certainly know a lot
about whales so looking forward to your
preview here
yeah for sure look like I said I don't
know anything about Portugal boys they
sometimes being closer to a country just
doesn't help you enough
um I've got nothing for Portugal but
like I was so surprised and so happy to
see uh the way Chile played I mean the
result was a bit disappointing but the
way they played so I'm hoping for for
similar from Portugal a like these teams
have turned up and showed that they know
what they're doing and they they can be
competitive at least for for a half I
think these sides all struggle when when
the bench comes on in the second half
and you get world-class fresh players
coming on against you
um I want to watch Jimmy is uh our dear
friend this week and former member of
your London gambling Syndicate Johnny
Williams comes into the midfield for his
first start like
against a team or I anticipate Wales are
going to be getting quality set peace
ball and a quick ball like makes Johnny
a serious serious threat in Midfield
like the guy can do it all he's got an
awesome offload game he's got the
longest arms I've ever seen on a man and
if he gets those through contact and
gets him free to like your Louis arm
it's in behind the Portuguese line I can
see him picking up a few assists uh he's
a fantastic ball carry he's going to get
him gain line guaranteed
um and he's a better ball player than
people give him credit for as well don't
you think Jim like you see space well he
distributes well so for me him coming
into a Midfield with quick ball and uh
some set piece domino saying he's an
easy picker in the Midfield to uh be the
one to watch geez that is a good shot he
wasn't in my team but I think I might
have to reassess because you're right
against that uh Portugal side he will be
all over them with those guaranteed gain
line that he always gets but they'll
only be one person cheering him home
more than me and that'll be Adrian has
um financial advisor
business he'll be looking forward to
that
um but yeah I've gone for um Rhys Emma
he's in my team like I think he's he's
one of the players this weekend he's
gonna be on the end of that back line
and have an absolute field day he is so
fast isn't he must be the fastest man in
the in the game I reckon he'd certainly
be up there he'd certainly be up there I
maybe some buyers I think Henry Island
was the fastest player I've ever seen in
my life but England won't pick him so it
doesn't matter
um but um it may re-zam it to my other
pick I went for Johnny obviously because
uh there's a bit of love there as well
but I do think he'll be a serious pick
and you might be able to get him on the
cheap because he didn't play last week
um but reason it's got to be looking at
hat trick against Portugal with his gaps
doesn't he yeah I don't want to give him
the James Lowe treatment you gave last
week but Patrick guaranteed triple
Captain triple Captain everyone triple
Captain him now there we go okay next
game is Island Tonga now this will be a
bit more interesting um first look at
Tonga a little bit like Samoa they've
brought in some X all blacks and a few
kiwis to sort of strengthen up the Squad
um what do you make of their side surely
yeah I think again we mentioned it kind
of in that first week of the preview I
was quite disappointed with their
performances and that pacific nation's
cup just because of how stacked they are
on paper there's so many big names
especially in that back line fikotoa
polu Charles Pier towel George moalo of
course unfortunately won't be on this
one but you just straight away expect
them to be right up where with the top
team so hopefully I think they're one of
those sides that the more time they spin
together the better they will get so now
they've kind of had a couple months as a
unit and they've kind of built a bit of
a culture so I expect them to be a whole
lot better than what we saw at the start
will they push Ireland I don't think so
I still think Ireland will get them in
that kind of 20 to 30 point mark But I
do expect it to be quite bruising and
it's one of those games for Ireland
where you're just hoping you don't come
out of it with some injuries because
Tonga wanna gonna want to bring the
physicality so Ireland almost have more
to lose than they have to gain yeah do
you agree with that you're picking that
sort of score from the Irish yeah
absolutely I've got Island by 25 down
here so I've split the difference under
there certainly but uh so I I came on to
disagree with people sorry sorry I mean
I I completely agree with everything you
said like his tongue looks so stacked
don't know that if you look at the
individual players in the lineup my only
concern with them this week is like
Ireland are such a well organized and
well coached team I think in terms of
pure coaching and organization they're
one of the strongest teams I've ever
seen and they absolutely thrive on guys
trying to do things by themselves and
coming out to find Solutions and it only
takes one or two of those Tongan Lads to
come try and tee off on Sexton or make a
big hit out of the line and that Irish
team one to 15 like they just they have
such Clarity on their shape they all
understand their shape they all
understand what they're trying to
achieve and someone will jump out the
line to hit Sexton and tag fur along
will put someone through a hole on on a
short line or one to Fifteen they have
that ability at the line so I think
while Tonga have a very very strong
Squad and I also anticipate probably
some injuries these These are the kind
of games that if you go up a few points
against them you don't come out
unscathed
um but it's just a really bad matchup
for Tonga like the reason I picked
Ireland to be the one team that can beat
Francis because they thrive on guys
being super aggressive against them and
trying to do their own thing
and uh yeah if any of the Tongan boys
try to try to jump out the line and go
for some massive hits then they could
end up under their own sticks yeah
that's a good point because I I agree
with you I think Ireland are the most
sort of in sync side at the World Cup
like now obviously play together a lot
throughout the year with Lance demo
majority of them and Leinster and then
add in a few different players from
other sides but they jump straight into
the the game plan of what they're trying
to do and they're all so in sync so I
love watching Island play and I do give
them a real good shout of going the
whole way so um it's going to be a good
game next game is South Africa vs
Romania
um South Africa looks sharp they'll
rotate this squad on imagine or they
have rotated their squad so
um what do you make of this side who are
we looking out for surely I noticed the
name four halfbacks and the 23 so if I
come all for creativity that's what it's
all about all awesome straight away yeah
they've got they've gone from 7-2 to the
opposite end that's seven one sorry
sorry
Orthodox here at Waterland so I've never
seen it four half decks in a squad and
I'm looking forward to it she's probably
a world first so yeah it's going to be a
different look South Africa team I think
and pimpy's the guy that I've
highlighted just because
I think he could have a day on the wing
he's a weapon anyway but up against the
week in Romania side I think he'll be in
for a couple tries as well I'm not
saying triple Captain I'm not that bold
I don't want those DMS spraying me but
yeah South Africa will still be too
strong but they've clearly seen it as a
week to maybe rest some of those
Frontline players and get some K's in
their legs like snake you mentioned
before against some of these potentially
lesser teams because the World Cup's so
long and it's all about rotation you
need to Peak at the right time and again
this is another of those games where you
could just have an injury that you
really don't need I didn't notice I had
four nines in the squad so how's that
work they've got one starting and three
on the bench and two starting two on the
bench Jesus just loves to Rattle people
doesn't he absolutely lives for it oh
even those um those signals that's
that's a lead oh may they meet a hundred
percent they mean nothing 100 is just
[__] with people on Twitter it's so
good loves it he'll have a new burner
account by the end of the week winding
people up the rubber ducky so good can I
pick ones to watch the whole front row
yes for a penalty try yeah like I can't
pick one guy out of that unit but geez I
touched on it in the in the review as
well like what do they call them the
bomb squad I can't imagine anything
worse than playing against those guys
man like so I'd if I don't know how
props go in the fantasy league or if you
get points for shove overs and stuff but
if you do dude stuck it with suffer from
rowers this week I can see them getting
a few more tries and a shove over you
get points for winning a scrum I'm not
sure oh mate get them all in triple
captain
I don't know who's awarded the penalty
try if it's a pushover to be honest it's
a good question for the world rugby
Association but
um the next two are probably the big
games well this is the biggest game of
the round for me Australia vs Fiji
um surely start with you
on Australia what are you looking
forward to on this one or who you're
looking to watch yeah we highlighted
that back three before I think if you're
gonna play a team at their own game then
those three are the lads that could do
it if that's the way they go so big Mark
and column Betty they both Fijian Lads
as well so they'll probably have a bit
of a Target on their head but if Fiji
kind of want to play that Razzle Dazzle
game and turn over a bit of football
then that back three can really make
them pay it's going to be a real battle
though for Aussie I think they're gonna
just have to try play that textbook
structure like Wales did play in the
right areas Force mistakes and then live
off those because yeah Fiji if they're
allowed to play high Tempo offload get
behind game line they'll they'll make
you pay as well so hopefully Fiji
haven't been too dampened by that
disheartening loss because that
emotionally would have really taken a
toll on them we saw big semi was crying
there at full time so hopefully they'll
flush that one and got back up because
yeah this is an exciting game for me and
I genuinely think there a shot to win
this game what are you going I'm going
to go PG one to twelve mate you know I
love an Underdog Story would be iconic
stuff imagine in a calendar year of
rugby if they can knock off England and
Aussie yeah crazy how good what about
you snake you won't be agreeing with
that surely yeah surely I think you
smashed it mate I think emotionally and
physically that game on the weekend is
going to take a toll on them they don't
have the same depth that they're like we
mentioned with the those big four teams
so you would imagine it's going to be
the same lineup to front up you know on
a short turn a short a short test
turnaround against Australia
um I've gone Australia by 12 because I
think two reasons one I just don't worry
about that emotional hangover from Fiji
man they put so much into that game and
to lose it right at the end
uh you know those guys will love their
country so much they love playing for
Fiji so much I can just see a few of
them really struggling to shake it this
week and and maybe take them 10 15 20
minutes to to get into this next game
against Aussie which might be too late
if what I think could happen is
Australia finally clicked this week I
think I saw glimpses of them against
Georgia last week and
George are a better team than people who
realize I think um they didn't actually
perform that well last week again so I
was but again they definitely don't fit
into that category with Chile and
Romania and stuff like that they are
definitely closer towards the Six
Nations teams the bottom end of the Six
Nations teams
um and I saw enough in that Australia
team to think that they could really
click
um I I'd love for you to do it man I
before the tournament I was anyone who
would listen to me I was telling Fiji
are going to win this group Fiji are
going to win this group
um and I would I'd still love them to go
for it but I just think they're unlucky
with the draw that they've had the two
games back to back
um and that combined with I think
Australia clicking it together and I'm
not going to go against Eddie Jones in a
World Cup man his record is his record
of teams turning up at World Cups is
just unparalleled over 20 years now so
the Australia by 12. Australia by 12.
all right I I find this game so hard I
could see it sort of going both ways
which is obviously the easiest answer
but I think if Australia control the
kicking game and like they did against
Georgia I think Fiji will really
struggle they do struggle to exit
um when they're camped in their 22 they
look to play a lot so
um they've obvious I think they kicked
the least in the comp
um just naturally they love to play
that's their natural instinct but
they've got so many game Breakers so the
game can just change so quickly we saw
it in the Wales game we're just two
tries sort of out of nothing back to
back and they've got momentum and
they're just so hard to stop so I'd love
to see Fiji learn like us like I said
I'd love to see them get to the
quarterfinals
um and I think they have to win this to
to get there I could imagine Australia
will beat Wales so
um if they weren't this one I think
they're a real good chance of still
making it so
um yeah we're winding home Fiji but I'm
not confident with it at all I think it
could literally go either way and it
will be probably decided by that man in
the middle who everyone is loving at the
moment which is always good to see but
the next game the last game of the round
England versus Japan
um we've spoken about England a lot in
the um review sort of side of it Japan
as well
um where do we see this game going snake
this is a game for you I reckon yeah
I don't know man I don't know how to
feel about this England team I think
they'll get over the line and I think
it'll be a similar performance to
Argentina hopefully with some some
better discipline like I know the the
red car for Tom Curry like I don't know
if you guys saw the replays from the
South Africa game as well like no one
knows what a bloody red card is these
days so I'm not I don't want to pick out
Tom Curry because it's so difficult man
like but when does an individual problem
stop being an individual problem and
begin to become a team problem if it
keeps happening and England keep playing
rugby with less than 15 players on the
field
so I don't know if if anyone get a red
card earlier and they have to go hard
work again and Japan decide to turn up
it could be a close game but
realistically I think England they're
just going to shut it down big Courtney
laws they won't change the team at all
this week I'd imagine that they will go
pretty much the same team that played
Argentina because both of us going to
want some consistency from that group
and he's not going to change a winning
team when they've not won before
um
but um yeah looks I'm too elangie from
football and then probably forward
kicking with momentum and maybe England
by 15 with a load of goals yeah any
tries that's the real question
yeah go on I'll give one two along he
gets over for one though yeah
it's over for one you really forced that
what about you surely do you think Japan
can get up no unfortunately I don't um I
agree with kind of what everything
snakey said but I think England will
just have too much quality across the
park hopefully more than one line break
and if they're going up in threes this
is probably a game I'll turn off at half
time to be honest because I have no
association with the English and I think
this is all the play they play at the
moment probably not going to win the
hearts of mutual fans and saying that
like being like a 10 you obviously
admired George Ford like that people
don't realize like everyone's like oh
drop goals or uh it's such a hard skill
to master so what he does is crazy he's
so talented but if you're sitting down
on the couch and you want to watch an
entertaining game of footy that's
probably not what you're after so
hopefully the English can score a few
tries I think they should be kind of
again 20 to 30 points better than the
Japanese days but whether that's what we
see play out it'll be interesting to
watch because this is a game where
England can kind of build some momentum
now they've struggle to get back-to-back
ones for a long time so yeah I expect
their top team to be out there as well
and that they need to make a statement
here it's a game of contrasting styles
again too isn't it it's going to be the
the strangle of England with the kicking
game and set piece and the speed of
Japan who love to play with Tempo and
quick balls so it's going to be
fascinating to watch the contrasting
Styles go at it but I'm with you guys I
think just the dominance of the set
piece and kicking game will be sort of
too much from England and I know people
don't like a joke I love a drop guy I
think it's an awesome part of the game
which is definitely underused because it
is so hard to do like you try and get in
the pocket and put a bit of fake
pressure on yourself and man they're
pretty hard to get over so anyone who
can do it consistently um they deserve
every three points they get so good to
see The Return of the Dropkick whether
we see few more I saw a stat England
George Ford kick more drop goals and
what was it eight minutes and the All
Blacks have in the last four years so it
sort of goes to show how many of the All
Blacks kick it's not in our repertoire
but England definitely and George Ford's
mine
one of the first thoughts when he's when
they're not going anywhere to just get
in that pocket and go up in threes which
is fair play
um and yeah I enjoyed seeing a few drop
girls yeah what'd you make of the drop
girl snake mate I think it it it's
thinking outside the box like it's seen
as a um a negative thing because it's
obviously kicking and then there's the
associated thing with kicking and
accumulating a score and it's not great
to watch but like me if I was playing 10
for that team which obviously I'm
nowhere near good enough to do you're
not far off like you're being hard for
yourself
thanks boys but um I don't understand
how else you'd score points at times so
for me I'd see it as like no different
to like a like a cross kick or or like a
tap and go like it is forward clearly
identifying in the week like
geez I don't know if we're going to be
able to get over the whitewash here so
I'm gonna have to find other ways to
score points when we lose momentum 40
out and like Jimmy said they're hard
enough to kick in training by yourself
after after the session when no one's
watching let alone when you've got 15
argentinians trying to chew your face
off
like it's a serious serious skill and
like it is a bit of a last resort a but
it's um
for me it's thinking outside the box and
like he deserves all the products he
gets for that because it's clutch and
it's such a difficult skill to execute
yeah I agree with you there I like that
as a very very good point okay I know
you guys aren't playing fantasy and
we've mainly gone through our fantasy
guys throughout this um preview but we
will get I will get a prediction from
you I want your finalists now obviously
the first round's gone so who you're
predicting to be in the final now that
we've seen most of the team start with
you snake
okay I'm not 100 sure on how the splits
work on the draw I've tried to work it
out but I I can't think ahead of time of
where Runners up and Paul win is
finished but I think France South Africa
like I said and this is my what aloud
caveat unless they draw island in the
quarters or semi then France go to the
final and I think South Africa walk
through potentially whichever side they
go through
okay nice one sorry boy sorry sorry
sorry no I I like that so do you think
Ireland will beat South Africa oh
um
it's a good game I don't know it's a
really good matchup I don't I'm sorry
Jim I don't know
um ask ask me the week of the game when
there's context and team selection and
stuff I can't tell you now man okay fair
enough mate we don't we don't want you
making stuff up we want facts from you
yeah the water lad listeners are serious
Code Heads I don't want to put anything
out there that I don't believe
fair enough and this I totally agree
with it so what about youth surely who
are your finalists well my heart is
telling me to go with the game we just
saw on the weekend but a flip in results
all blacks will beat France it'll be one
of the Great Fairy Tale stories a
massive turnaround the nation will love
the boys again and Fozzie will go out on
a high he'll become sir Ian Foster the
first bloke to an Ever potentially lost
his job and then gone on to win the
World Cup in all seriousness I don't
know if I believe that I think winning
the quarterfinal if we can win that then
we win it from there but that's going to
be the hardest roadblock for the rest of
our run home so we're almost targeting
that quarter final as the final but I'd
love to see all blacks France take two
when we have Sam Kane Jordy Barrett
Lomax that's not an excuse the French
was still way too good but we still have
some cabs to come back and really boost
this team and make our 23 a whole lot
stronger so fingers crossed black at it
as well cannot wait to see say that man
but it's an interesting one like we're
building to this quarterfinal but we've
played our big game against France which
we've lost and now we've got Namibia
this week we've got to buy I think we're
into Italy and we've got Uruguay and
then we're straight into a massive
quarterfinal which is basically going to
decide where they finish it will either
be against South Africa or Ireland don't
want to be playing either of those sides
in a quarterfinal to be fair so
um however however runs so if they are
going to do it they're going to have to
be very very good and they're going to
have to improve of what what we saw on
Friday very quickly another one I want
from your snake top dry score on the
comp I don't think that changed after
the weekend but who's going to finish
top try scorer in this Rugby World Cup
yeah if I align it with my predictions
then Pino has to be the top try scorer I
think like the guy just finishes for fun
and on the end of that French team he's
also he's got multiple ways to score
he's not a um he's not one of those
Wingers it's like a gas man from
distance on intercepts and long distance
line breaks and he's he's not a close
range pick and go finisher or a sort of
like horrible cross kick Merchant in
goal he does everything
um he's got multiple ways to score I
think his support players is um
fantastic he's a smart player and a
great athlete so panno is the one that
stands out to me right now as as uh the
obvious pick
[Music]
um
I wanted to pick somebody's not a Winger
but it's such an easy pick hey if I tell
you what if Ireland go all the way then
Gibson park for top try scorer there's a
there's a rogue prediction for you she's
the guy's support like the guy's support
play is unbelievable yeah right that is
it is a very Rogue shout I'll be very
surprised if he's in
um that sort of seven to eight the only
thing that could hurt
is if um Island adapters for half-back
policy then yeah you can tell us to win
this week yeah
and last one from your snake uh player
of the tournament Yep this is a real
bold one Liz I'm really going to throw
one out here um Anton Du Pond I don't
know if you boys have heard of him but
he's decent player for France
um I think he's gonna go all right and I
think a few people will be talking about
him by the end of the tournament yeah
mate well I think we both sort of agreed
with that one of France won the World
Cup it's yeah unless unless South Africa
win then they need to give it split to
the entire bomb squad six-man play the
tournament yeah oh mate well geez what a
fascinating Insight from your snake very
glad we got you on um good to hear some
European insight into the game over
there and surely as always very good
Insight from you coming from Greece you
guys together what a what a Dream Team
for the all their previous show
appreciate you both coming on absolute
Lads um no thanks for having meal man it
was really good fun to actually watch
the uh watch the games this week and be
sort of invested in having to think
about all of them rather than just uh
tucking one in the background while I do
the hoovering I really enjoyed it man
yeah good stuff love your work same to
you Sterly yeah go well Lads and enjoy
the code hey I feel a bit more informed
now about the old hemispheres you know a
bit more enlightened to a different
breed of footy so I'll be watching this
week with a closer eye yeah mate we're
all learning hey kick your goals boys
taking points see you later
[Music]
[Applause]